des tombes à perte de vue qui témoigne
de l'ampleur de la pandémie au brésil
pas un jour sans une longue liste de
victimes du coronavirus pas un jour sans
enterrement rien que ces dernières 24
heures plus d'un millier de morts ont
été comptabilisés dans tout le pays
les quatre suspects à diviser nos envies
nous avons appris que mon oncle était
soupçonné d'avoir le govic 19 il a été
envoyé à l'hôpital de bellavista deux
heures après y avoir été admis il est
décédé d'un arrêt cardiaque
je pense vraiment que nous devons être
plus attentifs aux copies de 19 car nous
réalisons vraiment ce que c'est quand
cela nous arrivait sur ce territoire de
plus de 200 millions d'habitants les
favelas sont en première ligne face au
corona virus qui se propage à toute
vitesse en raison de la promiscuité et
du manque d'installations sanitaires
à tel point que les autorités craignent
que ces quartiers pauvres ne deviennent
des foyers particulièrement dense de
kovy de 19 pour le moment le qu'ovide 19
n'est pas la première des préoccupations
pour ces familles elle n'y croiront que
lorsque l'un des leurs décèdera de la
maladie c'est dur à comprendre pour les
gens c'est quelque chose que nous
entendons beaucoup mais nous essayons de
combattre tout cela en donnant des
informations en luttant contre les fake
news en transformant un sujet politique
en quelque chose de plus rationnel qui
résonne auprès de la population
pour l'heure faute de tests disponibles
les autorités peinent à établir avec
précision le nombre de victimes et les
chiffres officiels restent bien en deçà
de la réalité
[Musique]